[Music]
pretty much everywhere you go insult the
breath of the wild can be dangerous but
some areas require more specific
preparations than others venturing out
in the middle of a thunderstorm or
scaling a snowy mountain can be deadly
if not downright impossible without the
right gear items and knowledge here's
what you need to know to survive in any
climate and be sure to subscribe for
more Zelda tips
it rains a lot in breath of the wild and
the main problem with that is rain makes
it nearly impossible to climb anything
you'll slide down most surfaces so if
you need to climb something and it
starts raining try to find a sheltered
area to build a fire and wait it out
build a fire by dropping wood with Flint
or red choo-choo jelly and striking it
with a metal weapon you can also shoot
it with a fire arrow sit by the fireside
to pastime note that you will be able to
climb very short distances during the
rain using X to jump up don't bank on it
though
if you find yourself in a thunderstorm
unequip all metal items weapons shields
and bows but don't worry about armor to
avoid being a conductor if you do end up
becoming a target you'll see sparks on
links body just before the lightning
strikes also be wary of scanning too
close to metal treasure chests or
anything
similarly attractive to lightning if
lightning strikes near you you might not
die but you will sustain a lot of damage
in some areas of Hyrule like mountain
peaks and the Gerudo desert night the
temperatures will drop to dangerously
low levels if you aren't prepared you'll
shiver and slowly lose hearts keep an
eye on the temperature gauge near your
mini-map the blue section is the danger
zone there are two ways to combat the
cold cold resistant gear like the warm
doublet and meals or elixirs that grant
you temporary cold resistance you'll
have access to both options very early
on spicy peppers warm Garner's and
summerween butterflies will all make
cold resistant dishes and elixirs and
can be found in a lot of areas check out
our video on cooking for more details in
the especially bitter cold you'll need
higher-level resistance so either
prepare a stronger meal or elixir or
equip multiple armor pieces at once be
warned though no amount of preparation
will save you from icy water use raft
tree trunks or ice blocks to cross
safely
during the day and Gerudo desert you'll
need heat resistance to survive again
keep an eye on the temperature gauge and
keep in mind that taking off your
clothes won't do anything no matter how
hot it gets in here like with cold
resistance you can either wear armor or
make dishes and elixirs that grant you
the effect for a period of time cold
darkness and chill Fionn trout are two
options for ingredients and both can be
found in and around Zoras domain inland
a roo region you can also freeze certain
ingredients like raw meat by dropping
them in the snow or icy water for a bit
to get easy heat resistant food that
also stacks in your inventory in
addition to high temperatures in the
desert there's a totally different kind
of heat around Death Mountain you'll
need the flame guard effect instead of
heat resistance or else you'll catch
fire and die pretty much instantly you
can buy fireproof elixirs from Gale at
Foothill stable to help you survive your
first trip up the volcano
last and probably the least of your
worries keep in mind that some areas
have strong winds and don't paraglide
against the wind you can however use the
wind to your advantage since it will
push round objects like remote bombs and
allow you to paraglide much farther with
that you're prepared to brave the
elements but there's a lot more to know
to get through breath of the wild so
check out our tips on how to make money
and how to care for your horse and
subscribe so you don't miss any more
zelda videos
you